all right
hopefully holy crap you guys
jesus yeah we're having no [ __ ]
problems with the internet connection i
know i was like i'm sitting there
talking and we're being funny and [ __ ]
and then i look at my obs
and it's like we're all froze and i was
like what the [ __ ] happened
it's all good i'm getting all kind of
air like i don't know
we're having some i don't know if it's
our wi-fi i don't know what the [ __ ] it
is we're having all right
connection problems is it well yeah it's
just it just keeps locking up
it's not an apocalypse internet it's the
apocalypse internet kind of
it goes in and out a lot look i took the
band i took the band-aid off how's it
looking i haven't seen it it's okay
it's actually not as bad as i thought it
was because man what a minute nothing
well yeah well because when i first did
it it just went
like blood went everywhere and i was
like oh man and i just like wrapped it
up really quick
there's a lot of little vessels right
there yeah because i was trying not to
get blood all over everything
[ __ ] [ __ ] bleed a lot so you know
just now when i went to the bathroom i
went to wash my hands and all my
all my bandages came off and i was like
oh that's like not even anything
oh man what a day three hours into this
[ __ ]
i went we didn't even like [ __ ] get
the [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] teasing these
people we gotta go ahead
i gotta go ahead and talk about this
[ __ ] case get this [ __ ] going
i don't know are you guys actually
listening well now well now i'm like
paranoid that
i'm not going to finish it because it's
like i didn't even get to the part where
they like [ __ ] shot everybody and
poison everybody yeah that's like the
importance
that's that's the goal okay get to that
kitchen the good part yeah
yeah so uh so basically all right so
they all get down there
um as i said it starts going sideways
pretty
uh soon after that it starts going
uh starts turning into a kind of a rat
culture where we're supposed to like
narc on each other
you got your armed guards patrolling the
compound trying to keep people from
getting out
um you know they're supposed to go to
basically they did a lot of [ __ ] like
jim jones would he had all of his
sermons and speeches and all of his like
anti-government [ __ ] and he was like he
would put it on um
loudspeakers and it went across the
whole [ __ ] uh compound
pretty much day and night so you
couldn't really sleep it's just you just
heard it like all the time like 24 7.
they would be uh woke up in the middle
of the night for drills
all this other kind of stuff um if they
did manage to
write a letter to their relatives or
anything like that like
outside if the letter said i mean they
were all opened and read before they
were mailed out so it's like if they
said any
anything at all like denigrating about
jonestown they were
basically just thrown away so all of
their letters and outgoing like
communications were
censored uh no one was really allowed in
to come see them
anything like that so um
at this point like i said jim jones
seems to have gone like just completely
off the [ __ ] deep end um he's
super drugged up all the time if you see
videos of him
right near the end like right shortly
before the mass
the massacre he seemed real tweaked out
like and if you listen to the recordings
like he even sounds like he's [ __ ]
drugged out he's now we know what drugs
we're talking about i don't even know
what drugs it was
i mean all of them that's my
assumption from what i saw it looked
like some kind of barbiturate
yeah some kind of downer yeah
he seemed like real um like
he does really seem like um he was a
true believer because
i think that he started taking those
drugs because he thought
that he wasn't maybe wasn't good enough
or he was always failing or something
but then the drugs that he was taking um
made him
like it almost gave him like the
opposite thing he's like now he's like
hey now i'm jesus christ
so it's like it's it's a lose loser to
me it looked like something kind of like
percocet
somebody said speed a couple of people
said speed yeah okay i thought it was
the opposite
yeah because some of the [ __ ] because he
would be like really [ __ ] drawn and
out
and it looked like something that was
kind of like a barbiturate or something
kind of opiate derived you know i look
like this [ __ ]
high but
i don't i don't want to get my theory so
yes but go ahead go ahead and go ahead
and read
okay you already touched on him
he's trying to run a whole colony and
that [ __ ] doesn't have the skill to do
so
yeah he doesn't have the money and the
resources yeah
and it's starting to fall apart on him
yeah and i definitely do so like not
excusing it at all because he was
[ __ ] crazy but
i'm just saying that i think there was a
point where he had a weird
contradiction of he thought he was a
piece of [ __ ] but he also thought he was
like [ __ ] god's gift
at the same time yeah you know i
remember seeing you know recordings of
it and hearing him talking and looking
at the situation
and to me at this point there's all
these people they're
[ __ ] trying to live under these
[ __ ]
roofed kind of like shanties they're
i don't know what you'd call them
they're they weren't buildings
they were just it was just a roof it was
like no walls
yeah and they're living in there with
all their children and he's watching
them and there's
no real walls and there's no real food
and he's
got them out there trying to build a
compound
and planting crops and crops aren't
going to [ __ ] bloom
for another year how the [ __ ] is he
going to keep all these people alive
yeah because people don't know what he's
doing you know
and i'm thinking that the stress is
piling on him
oh yeah knowing that look i got the
responsibility of all these people and
their children
to feed them you know over the next year
and we don't have the food or the money
to do so so i basically brought him out
here to die
and he legitimately thought that he was
being that they were all being
persecuted
he thought that we were all chasing him
the government and the media and
everyone he thought they were all out to
get him
he kind of thought he was in exile yeah
you know in a certain way yeah
so he starts taking these drugs to try
to chill himself out but it just kind of
gets worse he's feeling bad about
himself
yeah but he also has a god complex yeah
and that's [ __ ] real that's a
dangerous combination
yeah so you know he's like [ __ ] these
people expect me to be the god that i
am and i can't [ __ ] deliver he's and
he's coming across
as kind of like elvis in the [ __ ] las
vegas that's kind of what i thought
yeah he's like elvis in the gut and yeah
his face
and it's i mean elvis didn't do like a
mass suicide obviously but what it is
is that he's got like this feeling of
impending doom and dread because he's
gonna be
[ __ ] defrocked as a [ __ ] dude that
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
what is the way i said he had a shitload
of money and that's true like after the
mass suicide when they went through his
[ __ ] he had like
suitcases full of cash if that was for
him that was
i know that's what i mean so it's not
like oh i'm so broke you guys just have
to eat rice and beans like every day
like forever but i remember that i
remembered that he just he had
i think i remember that point i forgot
about it until she talked it out but
yeah i remember that i think what it was
is that was his getaway money
yeah probably so when this [ __ ] went bad
he could get away and he'd have enough
money to start another cult
that's what we gotta do thank you
[Music]
there's always a way to justify it well
yeah you can justify pretty much save
the first attempt fails i'll [ __ ] get
it done on the second attempt of course
that god will like that so here's my
money
yeah here's the money i'm going through
well like i said he got all the money
from the followers and it's like yeah he
did spend
a little bit of it on you know building
materials and [ __ ] like that but
obviously not
not enough of it you know i understand
the thinking
well yeah and and the thing about it too
like i said is that
it it's sad to me because i feel like a
lot of these people really did maybe
believe that they were being persecuted
and so yeah maybe our life will be
better we'll just go we'll go back to
the land we'll like live out
you know it probably sounded appealing
obviously or they wouldn't have gone
um but then to get there and
just incrementally like [ __ ] like oh by
the way we're reading all your
incoming and outgoing letters by the way
you can't call your family anymore by
the way you can't leave you can't do all
this [ __ ] so it's like
yeah i don't know it's just the way that
it happens is just like really
just by tiny little increments maybe and
it's just that's very scary to me
yeah so as i said at this point like jim
jones he's
thinking he's like [ __ ] jesus or you
know lenin or something
so uh as i said he thought everybody was
out to get him he
legitimately did seem to believe that
that he was um being persecuted they
were all like
you know tapping his phones they were
all like after him and [ __ ] um
so he started doing a thing that you
know other than
having his voice going like 24 7 over
the loudspeakers like so everybody could
hear it like all the time
he would also wake them up periodically
to do mock suicide drills
he would basically like have a big uh
you know container full of flavor aid it
wasn't even kool-aid
i know a lot of people say drink the
kool-aid nowadays but it wasn't even
cool it was like the
the bargain basement kool-aid that was
the [ __ ] it was called flavoring you can
get that [ __ ] at kmart
yeah that's what and that's why because
it was like super cheap yeah
and it's like hey it was like a treat
you know if you instead of water
because they couldn't afford anything
else so that's what he said so it's like
oh that's like your big treat yo it's
vaporizing that's freaking
kool-aid it is yeah it's like this like
super cheap [ __ ] yeah right
i was like watching a thing the other
day that said oh on sunday you could
have one cookie
you know that was i know right it was
kind of like that because the rest time
they're just eating [ __ ] rice and
[ __ ]
so uh so yeah so what he would do was he
would like fill up a thing with
you know flavorator water or whatever
and he would tell all the followers
hey this is poisoned drink it like to
show much you love me or to show how
much
um you know you want to leave this earth
or whatever
and they would do it so i feel like the
more that
it's it like i said this is a dangerous
situation because the more that people
did what he asks it's almost like
emboldening him
to go farther and farther and farther
with it and and for him to go farther
and farther down the rabbit hole
of his own insanity because like hey you
know i'm
saying this and this you know i feel
like this is maybe a crazy thing but all
these people are doing it
so maybe it's not so crazy so let's see
if they'll do this and then they do that
too
and it's like so maybe that's not so
crazy either so like i said it's
that's scary how it's like kind of just
ramps up like step and step at a time
until finally you're [ __ ] well he
normalized it exactly
that's exactly what it is you make it so
it's not
and this is exactly yeah and the fact
that he did this like
fake suicide drills and they knew what
it was they knew
that that that he was like i mean they
knew it was a drill but he was basically
hey if this is poison everybody just
drank it you know what i mean
that way we can go to heaven hey uh tila
i forgot what was the name
what was your what was the name for the
show
that you suggested you call the
personalities call the person i write
that [ __ ] down jake
well i wrote it down because somebody
said we should do a show about waco so i
wrote that down we're going to do a
couple of personalities
we're going to do that show all right
we're going to do or
it or would be something like that
that's a pretty good that's a pretty
good name
we'll hash it out yeah uh we'll decide
what day to do
like i said are are we gonna like
replace one of the matinee shows
yeah do it on a day that we don't or
something like that we'll figure it out
we'll do it we'll do us
we got this as a as a big show and then
we'll do that as a big show
for a trial we'll see how people like it
yeah i like it
you know we'll see yeah we'll see how it
goes we'll see how it goes
okay i think it's a good idea it is a
good idea
well like i said a lot of people liked
our side track shows and we do kind of
like side track it's gonna be like a
mega side track
a mega side track but it's gonna have a
lot more visuals
but we're gonna talk about some crazy
[ __ ]
that's the thing we just won't have a
script we won't talk about anything
like well i mean we won't have anything
planned we're going to talk about
we might have a theme yeah we might have
a little theme we'll see how we'll see
how it goes
i mean it does make it easier i mean
that's what i mean it's like it does
make it easier on these shows like to at
least have something to talk about
because then if like we
run out of like sidetracks we just talk
about it we go back to like the actual
thing we're supposed to be talking about
it probably what we gotta do is we gotta
have some kind of theme that's like
like a current thing going on for that
day or that
time you know what i mean the theme will
be pertinent to the time
and antonio says a live q a would be
awesome i'm actually i've actually been
thinking about
because a lot of channels i like do that
kind of stuff so and you guys could
seriously ask anything and i would
probably answer it depending on how
drunk i was what's going to be
interactive to begin with
yeah maybe we should just have that as a
component of all of them
like like we have a live queue and i got
to figure out how to get that [ __ ]
music going in the background because i
want some music it's going to be audio
visual
i can oh i can do it i can just cheat
you'd not you could do it yeah
i can do it on here we need to get a
soundtrack going and it's like a score
and everything
okay to play through while we're going
red mage says instead of oreos and
kool-aid i got stuck with flavored and
hydrox cookies
i remember those which is weird because
hydraulics came first
like actually oreo were like a ripoff of
hydraulics even though oreo are clearly
better
like hydraulics are fine we had them too
like we were broke
they weren't as crispy that's true they
were a little
although it might have just been because
they were sitting at the store longer so
they got staler i don't know i don't
know
i don't really need a different dough
yeah oreo dough was
more crispy and it kind of had a shiny
gloss on it
hydrox was not quite as crispy and they
were kind of dull
they were a lot more matte color than
that color yes they were so good though
yeah there was a well i wasn't a big fan
of oreos yeah i didn't
the hydrox chocolate ones weren't that
good it was the vanilla and i think they
had a strawberry
yeah the vanilla is good yeah but
honestly the only oreos like oreos are
good but if i'm gonna eat an oreo i
wanna [ __ ] double stuff cause i like
the cream i don't like the cookies so
much
but if i'm gonna eat like a sandwich
cookie i would rather have one with a
vanilla
cookie than a chocolate cookie i like
oreos
yeah they're all right gotta have milk
with that [ __ ] or coffee well yeah you
do you gotta dip it
i'm just saying that if i had a choice
to like pick a cookie
it wouldn't be an oral oreo would be
pretty far down the list
you know what i'm saying as far as like
if they're food if they're free
i'll eat them store-bought cookies and
sunshine
[ __ ] lemon cooler cookies those are
good remember those like
that's some southern [ __ ] [ __ ] right
i like those i like
yeah yeah yeah the sandwich cookies with
like the lemon cream in the middle
no they were a lemon they were
they were a [ __ ] vanilla cookie oh
like like lemon chips in them and
white oh yeah sugar all over them yeah
yeah yeah yeah they they're almost a
little bit like those like wedding
cookies yeah
yeah yeah yeah i know we call a cocoon
yeah yeah yeah
mississippi i thought you were talking
about those ones like sometimes we would
get those ones at the dollar store
it was like it was a box like this but
there was like a hundred of them in
there so
maybe not a hundred but it was like 50
of them or four dozen or something
and they were like sandwich cookies it
was like a kind of a vanilla e
flavored cookie and then like lemon
cream in the middle they were kind of
they were kind of flower shaped but that
that ain't [ __ ] compared to [ __ ]
lemon cool yeah i know what you're
talking about sunshine i think it was
called
sunshine sunshine lemon cooler it came
in a green box gravy yellow yeah
yeah yeah i remember that yeah and it
was just like a [ __ ] flat cookie on
the bottom slightly rounded on the top
it was a white cookie with [ __ ]
really strong
sour lemon chips like a chocolate chip
but they were living
and the whole thing was [ __ ] covered
in powdered sugar thick
remember yeah yeah i remember those yeah
a pecan version of that we just call a
cocoon
yeah yeah grandma used to make that
thing yeah you know make some cocoons
you know that yeah okay and then uh
yeah amanda marie says the girl scout
thin mints yeah those are delicious
i love the thing especially if they're
frozen
but if it well like i said if it's not
girl scout season
when girl scouts are in season um if
it's not girl scout season you just go
and get some keebler [ __ ] uh
grasshoppers that's pretty much exactly
the same
and they're also good frozen cookies are
delicious i look
you know what to be honest i was talking
to zach about this the other day i'm
like um
i really like those pepper farm ones and
particularly my favorite ones i guess
because i'm an old lady are the mint
milanos
i [ __ ] love them at milanos chess men
are good too the butter cookies that are
like
little chess people you know it's funny
what's that i'm talking about all these
cookies and stuff
when i was at mammoth mountain when that
poultry guy sat
my uncle red he brought
some kind of cookie or pastry
man i can barely remember i can barely
remember
and we were eating those things [ __ ]
before the poultry guys first started
it was like maybe the poultry guys just
wanted your cookies yeah no it wasn't a
cookie
[Laughter]
it wasn't a cookie it was maybe you
people in the audience could remember
what it was
it was kind of like a jelly doughnut it
had a raspberry filling and a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] bunch of powdered sugar on
the outside of it
does it sound familiar and it was
something you could buy it was like a
donut
yeah it sounds familiar we had a bunch
of those things
i know what you're talking about yeah it
was like a jelly doughnut
but you could buy it i think did dolly
madison make those things
oh maybe or was it or was it sunshine is
it dolly madison even still around
i doubt it he was eating to me and he
and
michael red was like oh these things are
so good
that's fine when you're a kid you
remember the [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] you
know what i mean
right i know yeah it had a raspberry
filling
and powdered sugar on the outside it was
some kind of a see now that's something
because i'm not
down with like i forgot what it was
called to a large extent i'm not rolled
down with like the fruit filled
kind of like i will eat something like
that but it's not my favorite thing
so i probably wouldn't have had those a
lot growing up my grandma was really
into those though
seeing short breakfast somebody said i
know them soft and buttery no that's not
what it was it was like a
it was like a uh it's like a jelly dota
oh pecan sandys oh
i love those oh and i also love lorna
dunes do they still make those that's
like shortbread
yeah goddamn lorna dudes we gotta get
back to the [ __ ] topic
trying to remember with raspberries and
sandy sandy's i haven't heard those in a
long time yeah
they still make those as far as i know i
think this thing that i'm thinking of
was a hostess
yeah thing and it was like a jelly
doughnut so they weren't
exactly cookies they were they were
cookies it was more like a [ __ ] jelly
doughnut you got
pre-made in a package okay and i forgot
what it was called
yeah but i'm seeing them now i can even
taste them
and man i don't remember well now we're
gonna have to do some online research to
figure out what the hell that kind of
there was a name for him
i haven't seen him forever but now that
i thought now that i'm thinking about
cookies now i wonder if like lorna dunes
are still a thing
i remember those being around like maybe
five or ten years ago because i remember
like getting some out of a
out of a vending machine but i don't
know if they make them anymore
i don't buy a lot of cookies or anything
like that somebody said jelly rolls
maybe
powdered sugar maybe no i don't remember
what it was called
mary's p the murray's pink ring cookies
i remember those
i think dollar tree has lorna dunes
that's what i thought i thought they
were still around
somebody said snowball no they weren't
snowballs
ah come on okay we gotta get back to the
show come on oracle says i want cookies
now
yeah me too oh well i don't think we
have any
we got granola bars i don't think we
have any cookies um
let's see so where i was okay so mock
suicide drills we did that already
so at this point uh there's a u.s
representative from california named leo
ryan now a bunch of
family members of uh people that were in
the cult in guyana
were coming up to this guy and being
like hey dude um
you know our family members are there
like our daughter our son or whatever
and it's like
we're hearing some weird [ __ ] from there
like we haven't heard from them
or like the letters we're getting from
them like don't sound like them they
sound like really fake so
we think that there's like some weird
[ __ ] going on so
the congressman was like okay um well
i'm gonna figure out what the hell is
going on down there so he gets um
together with a whole bunch of the uh
constituents and like the relatives of
some of the
cult members and um they're like we're
gonna go down there and do an
investigative
we're gonna figure out what's going on
because we think people are being held
there against their will
so he flies down there in november of
1978
um with a bunch of relatives there were
a bunch of uh i think it was three or
four
uh members of the press like the media
like some photographers [ __ ] like that
so all of them fly down there uh on a
plane
now november 17th they get there
and the congressmen and the reporters
they get brought into jonestown and
everything's like
cool like they at first you know jim
jones everybody seems very welcoming
um everybody there is talk about how
awesome the place is blah blah blah
um you know they have a dinner for them
they have like some entertainment and
[ __ ] set up for them whatever
um jim jones even said hey i'll you know
meet with reporters talk to reporters
but while this all was going on
a few of the uh people's temple members
had conspired to
write a note to the congressman and pass
it to them secretly being like hey
please get us the [ __ ] out of here
um you know some bad shit's going down
right so but they had to be like really
like on the dl to do that
so that made because it turned out they
found out later
that before the congressman got there
jim jones had basically coached
everybody
at the compound they're like you better
not say anything bad about this
like what are you gonna say when the
congressman gets here what are you gonna
say because they saw them as the enemy
um you know uh not only the congressman
but also all of their relatives that
come with them it's like look if
if your relatives believe with the
congressman they're against us and
you know you just have to tell them
everything's fine here you're here of
your own free will
um and you know then they'll leave us
alone but
that's obviously not the way it went
down
so uh so congressman ryan gets this note
from uh some people that wanted to leave
and um so basically what ended up
happening after that
was that the congressman was like okay
well whoever wants to go with us can go
back
with us so they're taking this
contingent
back to uh the airstrip where they came
in at which was a few miles from
jonestown they'd come in by truck
at first they thought it was fine but
they get to the airstrip
and then a whole bunch of gunmen pop out
of the jungle
who had been sent by jim jones and they
opened fire
the congressman was killed
a reporter and a cameraman from nbc were
also killed
a photographer from the san francisco
examiner
was also killed and a female people's
temple
temper temple member i try to say those
two words at the same time
who was attempting to escape was also
shot and killed on the airstrip now i
remember this [ __ ] from some movies that
they made after it happened
yep it was real dramatic by this point
and they pop up out of the [ __ ]
jungle with all kinds of submachine guns
and [ __ ] assault rifles
but do you have any idea what the
weapons really were oh i don't know i
didn't look into that
i mean it didn't matter it killed the
people so yeah in the movies they showed
some sophisticated weaponry you know i
mean
but i kind of tend to doubt that jim
jones had that
i think that [ __ ] was probably just like
some revolvers and maybe like a shotgun
like i don't know like i said i've i
can't remember like i've seen a lot of
the footage
yeah but and to be honest if i'm and
please correct me if i'm wrong i think
i'm remembering this correctly
but i think even some of the gunfire
at the airstrip was recorded because
well because the members of the press
were there and a lot of them were killed
yeah i remember that but they got their
footage yeah
um look at that again yeah
it's [ __ ] scary yeah they make almost
kind of like a horror movie about it
well they've made well remember like we
were talking about it earlier that movie
the sacrament which came out somebody
asked if that was old or new that's
i think it's 2 000 i want to see it with
either 2015 or 2018
i can't remember but it's good it's i
don't remember if it's on i think i
watched it on
netflix or shutter i can't remember but
i don't know if it's on there anymore
like i said ty west directed it it's
really really good but it's essentially
it's set in the modern day and they
don't call it jonestown they don't call
it but it's essentially
almost exactly the story of jonestown
they just don't call it that
you know what i'm saying yeah um and
it's like a found footage it's a it's
basically it's like two guys
from vice are going down there to
investigate this cult
you know what i mean like because one of
them and they're going down there with
like the brother of somebody that's in
there like his sister is in there and
he's trying to get her out
and it's so it's like that but it's said
in the modern day it's not set in the
70s
but it's really good so you should watch
it um yeah so all so all these people
get killed in the [ __ ] airstrip now
what a lot of people don't know is that
some
some people that were in the cults uh
they were not down with all of this [ __ ]
that was going on and they
either hid or they ran they escaped in
the woods before all the [ __ ] mass
suicide [ __ ] started happening because
there are a lot of survivors
from that um like there was this one old
lady
i think she was 76 or something like
that when when she realized that all the
[ __ ] was going down and he's like yeah
we're doing the math suicide [ __ ] now
she was like yeah [ __ ] that and she like
hid under her bed
and she just stayed under there until
everyone was [ __ ] dead and then she
climbed out was like yeah i'm getting
the [ __ ] out of here
and i was like that lady had the right
idea and like
you know the one guy there's one guy and
i can't remember what his name is my
apologies but he's on a lot of the
documentaries
um he was actually
i think he actually ran into the woods
right before like all this [ __ ] went
down and he hid out in the woods and
then
you know some of the um guyanese like
when they were coming looking for
survivors they found him and then he
went back
but his uh wife and son were uh
died in the massacre and he still like
feels really bad about it obviously as
he would
so um so basically what happened with
that
was that i guess once jim jones had
decided hey
we're gonna kill um you know the
congressman and all the
i don't know if he would have killed the
con congressman if other people
from the people's temple weren't
defecting along with him
i'm but i don't know i i don't know if
that's anything
because that might have been like kind
of the thing that set him off he saw
like
and it wasn't like a ton of people i
think it was only like 15 people or
something like that that were
that that were leaving but the fact that
those people were leaving that was a
betrayal
and he's like look the whole thing is
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] show it's like i
can't deal with it anymore and he was
like obviously off his [ __ ] rocker by
this point
so he just thought everybody was against
him and it's like everyone's gonna turn
against me everyone's like you know
these 15 people are going with the
congressman i can't deal with it
so um so once the congressman
was dead and he knew about that
um and all those people were killed at
the airstrip
he basically was like okay well now it's
time to let go scorched earth and he's
like now we're gonna do
the suicide thing which like i said he'd
been doing drills for that for a while
so this is something that he had planned
um
and he had kind of got everybody ready
for it
and as i said i do feel like he was a
true believer i think
that he really thought
you know we can't go back to the us i
mean and that was what he told his
followers it's on the recordings
look the congressman is dead we've
killed him and we've killed these other
people
so we really can't go back to the us now
because you know they'll kill us
so we're just gonna have to all kill
ourselves you know we can't live in this
world anymore
um it'll be a revolutionary act that's
how he sold it to them
um you know it's a revolutionary suicide
and he did use those words
so they you know the people that did it
willingly they knew what they were doing
they knew what they were they knew they
were dying um
and he's like it's just like going to
another plane of existence or whatever
so so everybody comes to the pavilion
like he calls
you know it's he even told like the
people i think he even told a few of
them like in his inner circle like the
night before look
look we're doing it tomorrow and they
were all like okay
because these were kind of like his you
know his main people
so he brings them all to the main
pavilion
and um you know gets everybody they have
they they'd had it all set up because
they'd done the drills before
so they had the big containers of
flavoring that had um
cyanide in them um you know which and
they had ordered like tons of tons of
cyanide from
i don't even know how long ago they had
done it but they had they had it like it
wasn't just like
an immediate thing and um so he's
basically like okay we're doing this
now some people came up and they got in
the line and they knew they were
drinking cyanide it's not like he fooled
them or anything like that and they
drank it willingly however
a lot of people were like yeah no i'm
not doing this [ __ ]
but at this point um he was basically
like
well if you're not gonna do it like
people were gonna hold you down
and inject you with it yeah um and if
you don't do it we're going to shoot you
so if you didn't want to do it you were
going to die anyway
um so that's what i mean so that's why
i'm not
you know i'm not uncomfortable calling
it a massacre because even though
you know a small percentage of the
people did do it willingly they're like
yeah give me the poison i'll drink it
a lot of people are like yeah no i don't
want any part of this especially once it
got to the point where like the little
kids
they were like well you have to you know
give the poison to your children
and then drink it yourself which is
another thing that he said on the
recordings
and you know and some people were like
yeah nah i'm not doing that
and then he's like well you have to do
it or like i said we'll hold you down
inject you or
or we'll shoot you so you have to do it
whether you want it or not now they're
reminding me in the comment section that
the name of the guys that he used to
enforce all this [ __ ]
was a group inside his cult called the
red guard yeah or the red brigade or red
brick
that's what it was they were running
around making sure all this [ __ ]
happened
it's [ __ ] bizarre man but uh
it happens you got a cult leader that's
[ __ ] drugged up
going crazy he's depressed because he's
failing
he's gonna leave and he's gonna erase
all these followers
i got a feeling he wasn't gonna drink
that poison he didn't
yeah he either shot himself or had
someone else shoot him yeah
they found him dead with all his
followers but he died um from a gunshot
wound it was him and one of his
mistresses i believe
um i've heard but i've heard um
conflicting i've heard some people said
that he shot himself
and most of the other sources say that
he had someone else shoot him because he
was too much of a [ __ ] to shoot himself
but he absolutely did not drink the
poison
so there was no plan to escape with the
suitcases of money no
okay which like i said that's what
that's what leads me to believe that he
actually did believe all this [ __ ] yeah
because he actually yeah he actually he
had all this engineered
and even though like i said he was kind
of shitty for
one forcing people to drink poison when
they didn't want to and he didn't
wouldn't let them leave obviously but
the fact that he wouldn't drink the
poison also
he was like well i'll just get shot i
get it though i get it
he's a messianic figure he's got a flock
of people he has to save
he takes him out there he fails he
starts taking drugs and gets depressed
about his failure
decides that he and his flock are going
to go to heaven
that's what it is yeah well that's what
he told them yeah
he said like i said he said we can't
live in this world anymore it's like and
now
that the congressman is dead we've
killed the congressman we've killed like
some of the you know
the journalists and stuff so we can't go
back to the u.s
um this will be he told them that it
would be
a revolutionary act like they will see
this and they will so there was like a
marxist
the theme behind all yeah yeah
he was he would have killed himself and
his flock even if they didn't kill the
congressman though
well yeah he was he was planning that i
don't think that he planned to kill the
congressman necessarily
he just did it but when the congressman
because he wasn't gonna let him in
but then when they got there and he was
and him and all that his
you know the relatives and stuff were
like you know look we're coming in there
and then he's like well okay well we'll
we'll try to make the best of this like
make it look like it's cool here
yeah but then when he saw that it was
going sideways he's like yeah
we just have to kill all these people
and then we'll kill ourselves and then
we're gonna kill ourselves just to like
you know clean the slate i guess is what
he was trying to do
because theoretically he could have let
this
he could have let the dude go yeah it
wouldn't have made a difference to him
really
he he was playing it by ear yeah i
definitely think that
like i said i think that there were pl
there were obviously plans in place for
a mass suicide at some point
but i think the fact that the
congressman coming down there and
you know looking into [ __ ] and the fact
that some of the
people's temple members were clearly
wanted to leave and were
passing him notes and stuff like because
they're like hey get us the [ __ ] out of
here
um i think that decided him and he
pushed it up and yeah he's failing
they're they're losing faith in him
he can't [ __ ] handle it he can't do
it he can't solve these problems
the senator comes exposes him
senator [ __ ] that senator congressman
congressman exposes him basically
and decides to leave and he's like i
can't let that dude leave
he'll tell everybody that i'm failing
yeah i think that's what it was yeah
and he kills him and he goes oh [ __ ]
i just killed the dude i just killed the
us congressman yeah they gonna
get me yeah well we could have to all go
to heaven
yep so that that goes to show you how
[ __ ] [ __ ] up his mindset was at the
time
from the depressions of the drugs yes it
could have
he could have played it this way that
dude's leaving no matter whether i kill
him or not
or excuse me that dude's gonna [ __ ]
leave okay
yeah and they're gonna find out all
right if i kill him
they're still gonna find out it doesn't
matter if he leaves or not
they're gonna find out yeah so i could
just let him
leave he'd live and then i'll kill my
flock
he could have done it that way yeah he
could have he could have
but he didn't but he didn't because he
couldn't take it i think
like you said he couldn't take the fact
that
he had failed yeah and for some reason
he thought killing the congressman
would hide the failure but then
like a dumbass you realize like no that
won't hide the failure
that just compounds that compounds the
failure
because they're still come looking for
him yeah you know yeah that was just one
guy
it's like if you do that kind of [ __ ] a
little more people are going to come
here yeah so he's not
really [ __ ] thinking clearly at all
yeah he's not thinking ahead beezna said
they tried to stab the congressman
before they shot him that is absolutely
true
he did actually go to the [ __ ] they were
nice to him at first and
they kind of like i said they kind of
had everybody scripted to be like yeah
act like this is
places like the [ __ ] bee's knees it's
the coolest place ever
but when he got that note from one and
he's like yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
here and he like kind of confronted him
and then they kind of jumped on him and
tried to stab him yet
the motive is to hide the failure yep
that's what he's doing
but that won't hide the failure
that was just an act of desperation he's
not thinking clearly
yeah i don't i don't think he was like i
said he had all that stuff
he had done suicide drills he had all
that cyanide he had all that stuff
so he was going to do that eventually
i just think the fact of the congressman
coming there just being
sped it up and seeing you know and
seeing how that played out
it didn't make sense though so that
tells me that he's [ __ ]
tripping he could have just said yeah i
failed okay go ahead
get the [ __ ] out of here well he wasn't
in his right mind he's not that's right
and he's like all right we're gonna kill
ourselves
there's no reason to add those people to
the to the [ __ ] body count but he did
anyway he did anyway
just people that came there like like i
said concerned relatives
people from the press that just goes to
show you that he's not thinking clearly
he's living in the moment
yeah he's not thinking ahead yeah he
just wanted to see what he was gonna
yeah he's a [ __ ] i mean
the people that escaped they basically
said yeah he was like [ __ ]
he was losing it it's a drugs he's a
crazy dude on a bunch of drugs yeah
[ __ ] uh was afraid afraid of [ __ ]
people finding out the fact that he
couldn't be the messiah that he was
claiming to be that he
failed that he couldn't even [ __ ]
start a colony
which is uh if you look at american
colonial history
is not an easy task most of the colonies
failed
that showed up here yeah you takes a lot
of money and patience and
pre-planning and a lot of work and well
in the thing
people that know how much work and
pre-planning it takes
sometimes can't make it yeah because of
you know [ __ ] that's outside of their
control
right the thing about it is that failure
is inevitable
um it's how you deal with failure that i
mean
you say isn't it you see well no i mean
what i meant was you see successful
people that's like you know this person
you know did this amazing thing but the
fact like
you only see their success you didn't
see all the times that they failed
on the way to getting to that you only
see like when they get famous for
example you didn't see like all the
years where they like tried to do this
and they [ __ ] it up or they did
you don't see all of that because it's
like hidden from you you know what i'm
saying
so that's what i mean by failure is
inevitable it's like you know
sometime in your life you're gonna try
and do something you're gonna [ __ ] it up
yeah if you what he's trying to do
[ __ ] when you really
look at the attempt he's trying to
colonize
guyana like
like the american like the like the
[ __ ] british colonists did
in america and that didn't work really
yeah [ __ ] the british colonies that
did
survive survived because they
yeah they built [ __ ] they started to
play they started planting stuff but
they immediately [ __ ]
usually connected up with the native
american indian economy
well you've hunted yeah you have to buy
and sell and trade
yeah you know i mean and he wasn't in
that position
you can't make something from nothing
yeah because there was i mean
where jonestown was there was nothing
nothing there was nothing out there i
think like the closest town was what
like 150 miles away or some [ __ ] like
that or kilometers i can't remember
but it was it was a while it was you
know it was far away
so and you know one guy that was there
he was like look there was no phones
there was no tv there was no community
so there was nothing it was
the middle of the [ __ ] jungle there
was nothing out there it's all done on a
bit on the back of his fantasy
yeah you have to be involved in some
kind of local economy
this is no way yeah i mean you really
can't i know there's this big thing
there's oh you know
self-made i can do this all on my own
but you can't though
if there's not an infrastructure for you
to like [ __ ] work within
you need tools you can't yeah what are
you gonna do
you can't do anything yeah you can't
build a
community like that no not without
something coming with tools and supplies
going in
i mean the thing is one thing that they
did do like one
um because i think i forgot to mention
this because i was saying that a lot of
their money came from like the people's
social security checks but another thing
they did too was that they
carved toys out of wood
and then they sold them in georgetown
so they were like making a tiny tiny
tiny attempt it didn't bring in a lot of
money but it did bring it a little bit
um so they were making a tiny attempt to
kind of maybe get into the local economy
even though like i said georgetown was
kind of a long way away
but they it was so remote
that you know what what are you gonna do
it's like you just get out there and
it's like there's
yeah it's a thousand people but it's
like you know you just have to kind of
rely on each other and he's running it
and he's a [ __ ] lunatic so it's like
[ __ ] man
it's it's bad yeah but yeah so uh ended
up like i said jim jones uh
him and one other person where the only
people found dead from a gunshot wound
whether it was self-inflicted or whether
someone else shot him i'm not really
sure
um i've seen differing sources on that
so the death toll and if you've seen the
[ __ ]
aerial photos of the [ __ ] it's
horrifying just [ __ ] bodies
everywhere
death toll 909 people
yeah i mean it really a third of them
were children
yeah it looks like something from a damn
african genocide in some civil war where
you look at it i mean
insane mostly black people laid out
there in [ __ ] clear clothes [ __ ]
dead
and like i said very few of those people
actually drank that [ __ ] like willingly
yeah happily a few people did escape
but i don't know man
that's how the [ __ ] would you ever get
over that
because some of them that was some of
them that was like their family they
left their family members like that one
guy that's on a lot of the documentaries
like i said i can't remember his name
but his wife and kid
his wife and son he thought they were
gonna be okay
you know what i mean he's just like you
know it's cool you know i'm gonna leave
you know i'll come back and get you
later and it's like
then that should happen and he's still
like thinking about it because
it wasn't me it wasn't a [ __ ]
mean-spirited thing that dude wasn't
[ __ ]
mean to begin with it was i think he
he thought well just drugs are a hell of
a drug
and [ __ ] you know an ego can affect a
[ __ ]
and uh religion
in the wrong hands and in the wrong
situation if you take it from the wrong
context
mixing it with the philosophy that they
had
trying to be more independent than you
really need to be
you didn't have to do it that way yeah a
bunch of other ways you could have done
it
yeah you could have bought up real
estate
in a town that functioned and integrated
in somewhere in [ __ ]
guillaine and just been a normal church
inside of a town yeah you don't have to
do that he's trying this [ __ ] trying to
make a whole new civilization
well yeah that's essentially not really
all that smart not that practical
no no no i just bought up [ __ ]
apartments
yeah you know in some town of guyana
and then bought a church yeah like a
normal [ __ ] would
well you didn't have to do all the
[ __ ] other [ __ ] that he did it's like
why couldn't he just
that's this that's what makes me so sad
about this i mean scientology that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] from the beginning but it's
like at least they buy
[ __ ] that's working that's true they
moved into clear water and clear water
has a supply chain
this [ __ ] it just seemed like it makes
me so sad because
it started out good it started they were
helping people they were actually like
doing [ __ ] and they seemed to actually
like believe in helping people and it
was like super cool and everything but
then it just
he just got crazier and crazier and
sadly a lot of people went along with
him in his craziness and
it just ended up in like one of the
worst [ __ ] things that you could
possibly imagine
it's like like you said it would have
been so much better even if they had had
even if he was a little bit paranoid
it's like yeah we don't really want to
live in the us anymore okay fine it's
like why don't you just go
like you said go in to a city and you
know
go go to georgetown in guyana because
they had a house there
yeah it's like don't go out in the
[ __ ] jungle and all this other kind
of [ __ ] it's like remote but i feel like
it got to a point where he was so crazy
that he's like we have to like hide
we have to be separate from the rest of
the world we yeah we have to separate
we have to isolate ourselves and that's
never ever ever ever a good thing
there's probably some kind of part in
him where he thought it'd be
cheaper to go out there and make your
own civilization
uh no not at all it's a lot more
expensive [ __ ]
starting from scratch out in the middle
of nowhere where you got to make your
own tools
to cut down your own trees to make your
own lumber
to make your own house just move into a
[ __ ] neighborhood
it's already there yeah there's already
[ __ ] there it's much easier it's much
much easier it's much more cheaper
it's a lot more efficient there's
already a [ __ ] power plant that's
[ __ ] going to sell you electricity
per month and there's just
no yeah it's like we have a thing called
society it's like it doesn't work
you know all the time but i'll link up
to it and get your [ __ ]
it's better than not having yeah you
know
we have electricity and phones and yeah
if it's much better trust me i think in
the future you know what i mean [ __ ]
solar and some of these [ __ ] pot you
know if you were living
real small out of [ __ ] like tents
you could probably keep solar power
packs charged up to do
simple things like running electronics
yeah have flashlights
you're not gonna be able to power
electric cars or any crap like that or
electric heaters
but you know if you're if you're trained
you know like
me being next to infantry i can live out
and [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] hooches hooch tents and [ __ ]
inflatable mats and some [ __ ]
sleeping bags and have all that [ __ ] i
can do that indefinitely i mean you've
got we got a homeless camp up here
a couple miles from here well we're
[ __ ] sick ten miles up the road no
not even not
even uh up there at that intersection
living out in those woods
and they're living good they have the
[ __ ] to do it
you know well yeah because they'll be
around them yes they just want to
[ __ ] go to the bathroom they walk up
to starbucks
yeah you know what i mean so um but i
could do that indefinitely it's no
problem
it actually is a [ __ ] easy life if
you have all the equipment
now is it as cool as a [ __ ] spread
like this no you want this
you know well yeah that's the thing if
you if you have
you know the means yeah to have to make
your life easier and like less shitty
then you do that then do it yeah
although man [ __ ]
look having lived in the wild for
extended periods of
as long as you have the right equipment
it is easy if the weather is good if you
have yeah
yeah like i said if certain parameters
are met then yeah
i can see that there's a youtube channel
of a of a filipino
girl that lives out in the middle of
nowhere and her whole channel
is about her and she lives in a camp
like that
like a tribal [ __ ] i think it's
filipino all right
it's a tribal area like their version of
them
mississippi or something and she puts
her [ __ ] bikini on
jumps in the [ __ ] water and pulls out
live fish in her teeth and [ __ ]
catches all this [ __ ] with her [ __ ]
hands
and takes it up on the [ __ ] top and
[ __ ] turns it into food and eats it
and she's [ __ ] she can hunt and swim
and
catch [ __ ] and she comes up out of the
water within her teeth cute too
you know then take it up there and eat
it and that's the way people lived
for millions of [ __ ] years yeah okay
and she's having fun and this happy but
she's
also got mobile devices she's recording
it that's what i mean
it's kind of like solar panels to
[ __ ] do her mobile devices it's like
like if you want to live like that i'm
not
you know i'm not i'm not [ __ ] on you
do it yeah do it
but you know i'm just saying don't like
make your life harder just for the sake
of making it harder yeah
it's different it's different a small
tribal unit
yeah in an area and it's different well
it's different if it's something that
you chose
yeah and they and they were kind of grew
up in that environment and you know they
run trot lines and they have the [ __ ]
houses that they need and
you know they've been out there for a
couple generations it's it's a lot
easier
uh now taking hundreds of people and
moving them out in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and trying to start a damn town
from scratch
too many people yeah that was like it
was like there was more than a thousand
people yeah
and they had not all at once but they
could that's how many came there like
when you have that many people you can't
do hunter gathering
you have to [ __ ] do crap farming
which is farming developed slowly from
small towns that grew to large towns and
that was because
it was a small amount of people growing
stuff
to yield food to support a larger
population which fed back into the cycle
to get a thousand people [ __ ] growing
in a single year
they have to have at least a years or
two's worth of food
until everything starts
yielding enough crops to feed everything
yeah because
that [ __ ] doesn't grow immediately you
gotta wait the more people you have
in a concentrated area the more
difficult it is
you can ask the mesoamericans down down
mexico and central america
they'd even have wheels of the roads
they had those temples but they had to
[ __ ] plant
in the same places over and over again
to support a city by doing that
it's a lot harder man the more people
you have
in an area the harder it is to feed them
well yeah you know a lot of people eat a
lot i'll go out there
you know if you give me a [ __ ] square
mile i'll eat my ass off
i know exactly he'll eat all of his food
and your food
on that now you move a thousand of me in
that mile
it's a lot harder we'll eat up all the
deer
especially a thousand
[Laughter]
and it's going to be hard to grow stuff
you know what i mean it's easier just to
hot stuff and eat it
you know that's why meat tastes so good
it's telling you something because
that's what your ancestors were eating
it's easier to catch something than to
plant it well yeah a lot easier
i read a book too i don't know i haven't
read anything about this in a few years
but a few years ago a book came out
[ __ ] who wrote who wrote that stuff uh
it was a biologist i think
and he wrote a book where he was
positing the theory and it actually
sounded pretty um
pretty plausible that you know how
there was that thing in human evolution
where the brain suddenly went whoop and
it like got super super good yeah
because of meat
and they think it was because of well
not not just meat it was because of
cooking cooking and fat cooking well
when you well because when you
eat well no the thing about it is that
when you're eating raw stuff it's like
harder
particularly for meats like to get um
you know all of the
you know nutrients from it but when you
cook it you're pre-digesting yeah you're
pre
essentially you're breaking down also so
this so the nutrients are more like um
you know you're getting them more easily
like digested into your
meat eating predators have bigger brains
if you cook it it'll get even bigger
yeah that's that
that was that was his hypothesis that
and honestly it sounded pretty uh
plausible
that that cooking it wasn't just meat it
was cooking cooking meat yeah yeah
i think the book was called catching
fire was pre-human
uh what was it homo erectus i think had
fire
yeah you know that was even long before
neater talk
so humanoids or hominids were using fire
long before humans were
you know humans are only 150 000 years
old
yeah something because i think i think
it was almost uh
what was it we got three million years
to go back to [ __ ] like
australopithecus i think it was about
like a million and a half years when you
when you're dealing with when you're
dealing with things like [ __ ] homo
erectus and i think they had fire
and you have to think too that ever that
they keep finding new
humanoids yeah like used to be back in
the old days you thought oh it was you
know it was
apes and then it was neanderthals and it
was humans that's not how it was going
though
yeah because there was a lot of other
humanoids that were like
essentially different species that were
you know yeah lived at the same time
one thing i don't really like about when
they show these so-called cavemen they
show them as [ __ ] primitive brutes
and that doesn't really stand up
yeah well and i've seen a lot of
scientists like [ __ ] on that too like
that's not
what you're talking about that's not
what it was like that's really reductive
what you're talking about is the [ __ ]
societies that are more kind of like
native americans which that's
sophisticated they were making tools
they [ __ ] had fire they could speak
when you look at the artwork and i could
[ __ ] do artwork when you look at the
artwork of some of that stuff that they
were doing
inside those caves it was sophisticated
airbrushing that they were doing
blowing out [ __ ] dyes to make
and there's a lot of gestalt in those
[ __ ]
images that they were putting on there
which is you know gestalt is like
it's not a wooden type it doesn't have a
wooden lifeless
image in in in what they're drawing it
looks like it's alive and moving
you know what i mean there's there's a
feeling behind it which is that's
that's some higher level that's some
higher level [ __ ] that's that's a very
human [ __ ] quality and we're not even
talking about humans i think these were
uh well they were humans they were very
early humans i think they were crow
mania
that was doing that kind of stuff which
what is that 100 000 years back that's a
long time
yeah and so
you were dealing with the kind of
hominid that you could chill with
you could talk with them yeah have a
relationship i feel like they wouldn't
be
that different people they wouldn't be
that yeah they were people they probably
weren't funny-looking
but well some people are funny looking
yeah
[Laughter]
no judgment yeah but no
um you could probably go back [ __ ]
even into the damn
homo erectus era which is like a million
million and a half i believe years back
and they were [ __ ] half the brain
capacity of us
but they were still doing some pretty
cool pretty advanced [ __ ]
you know what i mean they weren't as
advanced as a native american
or or you know a homo sapien but more
advanced to say like a cat
a lot more advanced than say an ape
although i have to say that even
like apes and cats and [ __ ] like that
they always surprise
me like with the [ __ ] that they can
figure out they would have been real
human-like
you know but you know what goes along
with that is they would
[ __ ] if you were to like do a time
machine to go back and chill with them
they would have immediately been alerted
they were like oh no this ain't right i
don't know what this is that
[ __ ] is ugly
look at his big fat head yeah they'd
probably attack you
i would think i mean if it was me i
would yeah which that would be the smart
thing to do if you like that
you big-headed [ __ ] that's right
right yeah clear your ass
let's eat that that's what after they
kill it they go i bet you that tastes
good
well yeah don't waste that put that
[ __ ]
asked you if you would you would refer
to cannibalism if you had to
oh yeah eyebrow yeah most people would
yeah i mean it would have to get really
bad but yeah
it had to be bad or i'd have to be
pissed off as a [ __ ]
there had to be something about you yeah
you'd have had to make me really really
mad that would be really fun to make
money
i'm like you know what man are you going
to end up on it's like
that's what i mean it's not enough for
me to just kill you i'm gonna i'm gonna
eat you and [ __ ] you out right which
that well yeah
that sounds really horrible to a western
person you know what i mean a [ __ ]
you know what i mean a modern background
but that's because you're not really mad
all right you're not really pissed off
you're not in a tribal situation i mean
that was going on in the islands
i was [ __ ] served in the army with
micronesians
and [ __ ] um what he called samoans
that killed and he ate each other
[ __ ] in tribal warfare
not too far back and
if you really hate him [ __ ] uh
you
you can you can i can kind of understand
it i can see that
especially if you're in a situation
where it's a tribal situation and
everybody knows the deal and
meat isn't wasted because that's a
valuable commodity
because big game on islands is kind of
hard to come across
you're gonna it's and if you've ever
feel dressed a deer
it's not a real gruesome process it's
just like you know
i can [ __ ] take a deer and get the
filet off the [ __ ] spines and get
your [ __ ] hind quarters and
everything
and as long as everything's field
dressed and [ __ ] you gotta
you feel dressed that [ __ ] first when
she's taking all the guts out
and then later on you string him up and
you're skinning him and you're [ __ ]
it's it's it's just like going to the
to the grocery store and seeing the
pre-packed meat it's not
real gory with a bunch of blood
everywhere
so if the head the hands and the feet
are off of the human during that process
first
as you get into the process after the
field dressing process
it doesn't look a whole lot different
than a deer or a pig
as long as they weren't looking at you
yeah so you can make see the jump that
they're making
in their mind they're going like well
now that the face and the head is off of
it
we're going to shrink that [ __ ] down
into a [ __ ] trophy
and the hands and the feet are off of it
boy it looks a lot like a pig doesn't it
yeah well you know and they're gonna
even when i'm eating even when i'm
eating
like meat meat like a cow or a pig or
something like that i still don't want
that [ __ ] face on there
yeah you don't want that little baby
looking that's what they're doing
they're going like you know what hey
that thigh that's a lot of meat
yeah let's go ahead and let's not bury
this part let's take this part off
yeah we'll marry we'll eat that the rest
of it that's what they're doing yeah
let's make some stew out of that [ __ ]
yeah i've been i've i i have read about
people that i
imagined like you know because i write
about a lot of serial killers and stuff
like that
and i was thinking to myself sometimes
like if that dude like broke in and was
doing some [ __ ] to me and i somehow got
the better of him i would totally eat
him
because i would be mad enough if you
look at tribal warrior societies
ritual cannibalism after some kind of
combat type
deal they'll say what's to gain their
strength
yeah i don't believe that i just it's
more about like to make yourself
stronger that's
that that meat's expensive but i'm
gonna that's played out in the [ __ ]
movie you know with the hannibal lecter
you know what i mean
and and like hannibal rising really good
movie go see the movie hannibal rising
that'll explain to you
how a [ __ ] might adopt
cannibalistic
tendencies against his enemies
you know yeah it's also psychological
warfare
yeah okay well because that's some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] to do and that's like
scares people
and your reputation gets around so
you're on an
island everybody kind of knows each
other you killed some dude
because he was a bad [ __ ] and
you ate him and all of his friends now
have received that warning
don't [ __ ] with tom he ate jim
[ __ ] his ass out when he was done with
it [ __ ] will eat you
yeah he'll reduce you down to [ __ ]
antophy
or something like that you know reduce
you down to [ __ ] you know
gumbo he'll throw you in some bricks
yeah put you in the grits
is that something you do in a modern
society no
it's a lot easier just to buy it well he
has to buy some yeah
you're talking about a different there's
a different situation
with a different psychology and the
dudes that did were doing this
hated each other this wasn't something
that you did
to your friends you know excuse me
getting hungry elsa is like don't [ __ ]
with tom he ate jeff i'm just saying
that's what they're doing well and like
i said i
i can totally understand like somebody
does something
so [ __ ] up to you that it's like you
kill them and that's not good enough
you have to like [ __ ] take away their
dignity even more
yeah because killing them wasn't enough
reducing them to food
right to like sate your hatred of them i
get that yeah and it's not
a sexual thing like like a serial killer
might do yeah that's not
that's that's a different thing this is
an anger this is an anger thing yeah
and and then that's where all the
shrunken head action came from
you're not going to eat that but you're
still going to use that head as a
warning to those other things i'm going
to hang it on my
[Laughter]
and every time you come [ __ ] with me
on the end of this [ __ ] staff that i
have i'm gonna go like that
you're gonna see jim's head shrunken
down to nothing
to [ __ ] [ __ ] with me you're going to
be just like
jim right there next
that's exactly what they're doing yeah
which like i said that's totally
that's totally interesting it's a modern
veteran i know exactly what they're
doing it's totally understandable would
i do it
not in a modern world in a
post-apocalyptic world mad max [ __ ]
you're going to do whatever you want
you're going to do whatever you have to
do to survive
tila says her pizza is starting to taste
different now
tastes like human meat sorry in a
survival situation
you do whatever you need to flourish and
to survive and
intimidating potential enemies
is a huge survival uh
uh bonus and it attracted mates
yeah you think that dude with the
[ __ ] heads you think the girls
were running from him no they're running
running to him
because he had a reputation he's got
jim's head got jim's head
he can protect you if a [ __ ]
bad man come he'll kill the bad man he's
got proof he's got the heads
and the other men are running away from
him now because he's got those damn
heads
and that's what it is and you can live
with him
and you can have a baby and raise the
baby you can even have little dogs and
cats
and other men won't come that's what it
was because he'll eat their heads or
he'll look at his health
yeah just scare him away and if they
don't scare him away he'll [ __ ] eat
them and then you have some food
that's what they're doing can i just say
i love this entire conversation
[Laughter]
that's the rationale behind teaching
these people something
they ought to know by now i'm running to
the guy who has
jim's head yeah i'm trying to put it in
i'm trying to put it in the context of
white you white folks relate to
tom and jim
i'm gonna shrink some heads yeah don't
[ __ ] with us it will shrink your head
and put it on its desk
tennis ball
the whole the whole scalping thing was a
lot like that
yeah it was anything like that you're
taking a trophy
like [ __ ] the difference is is that you
know that [ __ ] started coming from the
north american
indians it was faster you didn't have
time to do all that [ __ ] like
well that yes taking skin off the whole
head and then shrinking it that's like
shrunken heads for lazy people like me
there's like look i don't have time for
that [ __ ] i'm just gonna cut your
[ __ ] hair off and it's like look look
well you're out on the planes and you
[ __ ] jump two or three dudes and you
kill all three of them
you got to get the [ __ ] out of there
before there's retaliation so you real
quick
yeah wow you're popping those scalps off
the top of those [ __ ] heads
to prove your kills because i will say
that shrunken headery is
that takes a long time takes a long time
then you jump back on your horse and get
the [ __ ] out of there
and then you show your buddies look got
three of them oh hell yeah
how much you want for them because they
were selling them yeah
they were selling them too i'm gonna
make a coat out of that and i'm gonna
[Laughter]
tell y'all something this is true
[ __ ] one of the biggest ones that one
of the biggest markets for those [ __ ]
scalps
and the biggest purchasers in terms of
[ __ ]
if you really wanted to make money off
of [ __ ] human scalps
was england there were whole [ __ ]
expensive manners and [ __ ] [ __ ] the
old skeletons
[Laughter]
as if it was some curio from the [ __ ]
america oh
scout from that wild and savages yeah
i'm gonna throw this on you
i throw this on you because this is
another thing that was [ __ ]
that was mentioned in the [ __ ]
literature of the time
a lot of the scouts were white people
scalps of white people too
because a lot of white people would go
[ __ ] so there were white people in
those indian
tribes they scalped you you know what i
mean
just because it was a scalp or an indian
scalp didn't mean that that would that
that scalp wasn't a caucasian indian
yeah so there's a lot of [ __ ] that that
you know what i mean
that hollywood doesn't kind of [ __ ]
impart on you
just because you were an indian didn't
mean you were a caucasian
that happened too or vice versa or vice
versa right
tammy said the thing about this show is
we never know what topics we will end up
talking about
same i never know what are you doing
what we're gonna end up talking about
either
yeah but that's what's fun that's what's
so fun that was back in the day we're
talking about jonestown and now we're
talking about
india's gaps we're talking about coats
made of human skeletons yeah
they did everything how did that happen
who knows yeah
we're just glad that [ __ ] went down in
the [ __ ] 20th century too you know
what i mean people
the japanese and the germans were taking
[ __ ]
uh human skin that had been tattooed
that was the thing
that well did they do that in vietnam
too didn't they take it ears and [ __ ]
like ears
you know the uh the jack the imperial
japanese
high-ranking officers were just
fascinating fascinated with
tattoos so white guys a lot of times if
they were killed their tattoos were cut
off and they'd end up in japan
yeah i've heard that yeah they were
being collected they're pri
they would actually display amer
american gi
so uh prisoners uh because they had
tattoos they were just fascinated with
tattoos
the japanese were just they had a tattoo
fetish
back in those days that's kind of a
weird thing but fair enough
yeah you ready to
i'm ready wrap it up okay one thing i
did want to mention
uh before we get off the topic of
jonestown which i guess we already did
like i said there are a million
documentaries about this one of them
and i wish i could remember the name of
it it was one that i saw several years
ago in the theater
that was pretty much all archival
footage from the time
um i don't know if i'd recommend it
because it's [ __ ] horrifying but um
you know if you're into that you can
watch it i will say and this was
something that i didn't know
so 909 uh you know people
died more than 400
of them the bodies were unclaimed
so all of them were buried like in a
mass grave
at evergreen cemetery in oakland
california and they have like a stone
memorial there
because all those bodies were not
claimed i didn't actually know that
that's really [ __ ] sad i don't know
maybe they just didn't have family
members
i guess not but that really bummed me
out like right because that's like that
was like half of the people
that were there family members that
could afford to go claim them
yeah maybe yeah that's pretty sad though
but yeah they just they put the uh
memorial there in like 2008 so
fairly recently but uh yeah so that's
pretty [ __ ] up
all right so um you ready to wrap it all
up yeah wrap it up
so like i said sorry about the [ __ ]
glitch in the middle i don't know what
i'm gonna do with this now am i just
gonna leave it up in two parts or am i
gonna have to like edit it all together
i don't know i'll figure something out
i'll probably like edit the audio
version together but i'll probably leave
the video version like it is because
[ __ ]
i don't have time for all that [ __ ]
but uh yeah so remember
uh like share subscribe if you haven't
already
uh if you want to support us on patreon
patreon.comclef podcast
uh you know or you can go to our blog 13
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a paypal account
if you'd like to give us a one-time
donation anything would be much
appreciated
we also like i said at the beginning had
set up a amazon influencer storefront
so if you want to buy any of the books
that i've reviewed or any of the
movies that we've reviewed over the
years you can go to our little amazon
storefront
and buy the [ __ ] from there and we'll
get like a couple pennies or something
like that so if you're into doing that
and we will do another live stream
what it's saturday right okay so we'll
do another live stream tomorrow probably
talk about a movie or talk about some
other [ __ ] we'll figure some [ __ ] out
yeah and we'll start planning for the
new
yeah i actually do actually like that
idea so
i like that so we'll uh we'll try to
decide like what day to do that on
yeah like i said maybe we can do it like
in replacement for another
for one of the matinee shows like even
if we have to switch days out
you know what i mean yeah you know what
i'm saying we'll do it evening our time
kind of like this yeah because i do kind
of i do kind of like doing them in the
evening more
i know i know that that's i know it's
not the same for everybody
like in all the time zones and stuff but
it's better for us because
it's not too late at night because we
start at 5 p.m but it's
you know we can still start drinking
without feeling too bad
but it's still not so late that by the
time we're done we're not just kind of
like oh my god it's midnight uh you know
what i mean so it's kind of like a good
time for us
i don't know we'll we'll throw around
some ideas we'll talk about it tomorrow
again tomorrow i guess
all right so we will see you guys again
tomorrow thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks for donations thanks
for being yourselves we'll see you guys
again tomorrow
bye